they come up with this idea for instance
that there are indigenous people who
were who were who were moved out the
Palestinians are indigenous people and
they were moved out by the Jews you can
do that if you want now let's do Britain
you want to play the indigenous people
own the land first game and the other
people should off I do not want to
live in a country with Hamas supporters
I want them deported I want them chucked
out simple if there are people in the UK
who are offended by the posters of
missing Jewish children they must
leave Douglas you're back for the I
don't know which time but we've had you
on many times and I put it to you that
there's good news and bad news the good
news is that you were right the bad news
is that you were
right what have you made of the last
three
weeks um well uh I suppose like all of
us it's a mixture of things first uh
shock then horror then shock again then
horror then disappointment and then rage
probably in roughly that order um horror
at what happened in Israel shock shock
like everyone this was able to happen
horror the details of what happened
shock then at the response on the
streets of cities like the one we're
sitting in in London the fact that there
were so many people who didn't even
didn't even give it a day before they
turned out on the streets of my
city
um supporting the people who' done this
act of
Terror uh and then in the weeks since
increasing
rage uh rage that I have to share a
country with these
people
and I think the thing that we've all had
to come to terms with is how some people
have just been so open about supporting
an extremist islamist terrorist group
and also refusing to acknowledge it as
such well before you answer Douglas one
of the things that I've noticed in in
comments as people like well these the
these are pro Palestine marches and I
think we have to be clear that what
we're talking about is in the first two
days prior to Israel responding in any
way there were people celebrating yeah
you did the bodies of the Dead hadn't
even been found they were still warm in
some cases some people were still in the
process of being massacred uh and even
as that was still going on
uh people were already out in the
streets of cities like London um uh
protesting against Israel and that was
what it
was um it was straight away a protest
against
Israel and you know look there are lots
of fine delineations you can do about it
some of which are true and some are not
you could claim that the people who've
come out in recent weekend on The
Saturdays care about Palestinian lives I
don't think they do I just don't think
they do
and I'll tell you one reason why is that
nobody in the Middle East apart from the
Israelis cares about the Palestinians a
jot I've traveled around the region I
spoken to enough people including
leaders of other countries in the region
to know the jordanians do not like the
Palestinians at all they find them an
unbelievable encumbrance and that's why
they haven't opened their borders to the
to the the people in the West Bank who
should effectively be in Jordan the
Egyptians loathe the Palestinians uh the
authorities of keeping the border
between Egypt and Gaza closed because
they hate the Palestinians I know people
who were born in Gaza uh when Gaza was
run owned by Egypt uh if Egypt wanted to
solve the Gaza problem it could do so
tomorrow by taking control of Gaza or
allowing the people of Gaza to go into
Egypt where they should
be um nobody else in the region
cares the qataris host Hamas and fund
Hamas as well as of course pumping
billions of pounds into countries like
this one to make us deeply
compromised um but nobody in the region
cares about the
Palestinians um certainly nobody cares
about them more than the Israelis who go
to incredible efforts to try to limit
the deaths and the the mistreatment of
the Palestinians even as the the whole
region the world has given them these
people to look
after um nobody really cares about the
Palestinians and Frank the idea that
Muslims care about their brother Muslims
is Absolut rubbish I think we flattered
much of the so-called Muslim Street by
even pretending this in recent years you
know hundreds of thousands of Muslims
have been killed in Yemen in the last
few years and there hasn't been a
protest 1% of the size of what we've
seen in recent days and weeks in the
west hundreds of thousands of of Muslims
have been killed in Syria in the last
over a decade since the Civil War in
Syria by Assad by the Assad regime by by
rival jihadist groups by interreligious
sects and much more and we haven't seen
1% of the people who turned out on the
streets this day the idea that Muslims
actually care about their fellow Muslims
is insane they don't what they care
about is
Jews there is something at the very root
of Islam and followers of the Muslim
religion who cannot
bear any any war in which Israel is
fighting and most of all loathes any war
in which Israel is winning and you can
see it it's at the absolute core of
their being this is why they are on the
streets of this city and others marching
it's not because they love fellow
Muslims is because they hate Jews what
so you're saying there's something at
the root of the religion well let's
tease that apart what what do you mean
by that well there's two particular
things worth mentioning one is of course
that Muhammad the founder of Islam
himself beheaded massacred many many
Jews famously there one one battle in
particular um and the the Banu it's a
story you can find in the um in the
Quran and the Hadith uh and of course
this is because the Jews would not
accept the revelation of Muhammad such
as such as it was and so they were one
of they were are seen within Islamic
tradition as being one of the first
people who turned down the opportunity
to join Islam and as a result of course
Muhammad uh
decapitated hundreds and hundreds of
Jews um so that's not a good
start but there's a bigger thing I think
within the Muslim World which is worth
mentioning which the late Bernard Lewis
pointed out uh on a number of occasions
which is the great problem within Islam
when it comes to not just Judaism but
the wider non-islamic world is
that the Muslim religion claims to be
the last Revelation from God to man
which we all know is a very large claim
to make it says there have been previous
Revelations but this is the last and
final one and what's more God has given
you a book the
Quran and the Quran is the one book you
need the opening uh sorry no here is the
book wherein is no doubt which is quite
a bold claim as well I'd say um but the
the the the claim of the foundation of
Islam is here is the book wherein is no
doubt and it's the only book need and
it's the final word from God that man
will ever have now if you are the
recipients of this book the people who
are end up either converting or or being
forced to convert to Islam and
eventually the areas that Islam takes
over by force if you are somebody who's
brought up in that tradition um you
would think that being the recipient of
the final Revelation from God you would
be in a just tiptop situation you know
you would imagine that well this is
going very well we've got the final
Revelation from God what's not to like
what's not on our
side and then several things happen in
the Millennia since which is first of
all many many Muslims realize that
despite having the final Revelation from
God things don't seem to be going very
well until oil is discovered in certain
parts of the Middle East most people
live in total
destitution uh the discoveries and
enlightenments of Europe largely passed
some Muslim World by this shouldn't be
exaggerated certain parts of the Muslim
world of course give the Western World
certain parts of what becomes the
Western European tradition so there
there were times of interplay there were
times of of mutual learning and now of
course everyone looks back at them or
many people look back at those times
with um with Nostalgia nevertheless in
the main the Muslim World cut itself
itself off from the rest of the world
and didn't care to learn from the rest
of the world uh didn't improve the
economic conditions of its people um
totally failed to create so societies
anything like as successful as for
instance European societies and um and
there in a question arises which is if
we are the recipients of the final
Revelation why is everything so awful
where we
live and then you have the additional
thing which is and how come the Jews
return or reestablish the of course many
Jews already living in in in in the area
that's now Israel um but already lived
there but many others come from other
parts of the world including from the
Middle Eastern countries where they're
chucked out by the governments in 48 and
so on um the the Muslim World sees this
tiny tiny bit of land this tiny bit of
land which among other things is the
only bit of the Middle East that doesn't
have any
oil and they make of it a much more
successful country than any of the
countries
around now if you create a Palestinian
State you just have another failed Arab
State another failed Muslim state to add
to the more than 5050 already failed
Muslim and Arab
states what is the explanation Jews who
refused the prophet's invitation to
Islam are still here have this tiny bit
of land and make all of these
discoveries and and other things that
that show themselves to be so successful
it's there some kind of stab in the
heart it in and instead of saying we're
doing this
wrong the thing is the Jews are doing
something right and that must mean that
they've rigged the
game that's why they care among other
things and it leads to the Deep
pathology of anti-Semitism which has
been largely eradicated in Europe among
Europeans not entirely but largely there
are still some bits of the far right you
can find across Europe and occasionally
in the UK where a sort
of the whiff of this noxious thing still
emerges on the left of course it's much
more it's much closer to the
boat um but principally anti-Semitism in
our own day of the kind that we hoped
ended with Hitler exists and indeed
thrives in the Muslim world and the
Muslim world is now in our world in
Europe and so we have the uh hitlerian
horrors of anti-Semitism back well I
have no doubt you're right Douglas but
one of the things that I think all of us
have been struck by in recent weeks is
that the Pro Palestine cause let's put
it in that in that language as they do
is very popular among young people in
fact I'm sure you've seen the polls
which show that young people believe
that Hamas attack was genocidal and
believe it was Justified on the basis of
what is they are pro genocide it seems
to be and not all of those people are
young Muslims in this country some of
them are not how did that happen um
fantastic ignorance I mean does anyone
around this table anyone watching
honestly think that we have a generation
that is well
educated toche I mean find me the
teacher or find me the professor at any
University that in the last 50 years who
would say to you every year the
undergraduates come up the students come
up and they just know more and more each
year maybe in certain Sciences you could
say in a particular field you couldn't
say it about the humanities at all you
couldn't say it in most fields
um certainly don't people don't come up
every year knowing more and more
history um the reason why the young uh
people you talk about believe this is
because they have been fed a form of
indoctrination in a particular version
of the history which effectively as you
both know maps on a very specific and
perverted version of American racial
history and Maps it on to absolutely
everything in the rest of the world add
to that a particular form of
anti-colonial history postcolonial
history whatever you want to call it
which knows no knows nothing of
colonialism but knows only about the
postcolonial world and you also see that
that is mapped onto the Middle East so
these people who um talk about Israel
and probably couldn't point to it on a
map they certainly don't know which
river they mean when they chant from The
River To The Sea they couldn't find that
on a map that's for sure from the river
to the Z of course I've chanted it do I
think that all Israelis should be pushed
out of the country or Jews or should be
treated like this or no do you know
which river and say they're talking
about by the way I don't know the uh the
riv uh I know the Mediterranean it would
be the sea but now I would know the
river no okay
that's okay perfect thank you these
people talk in what terms um they
basically fall into two groups they talk
in terms of
occupation
colonizers uh
apartheid this is the the
Americanized racial
Justice version of this mapped onto the
Middle East that the Israelis are
colonizers for instance and that they
are indigenous peoples and the
Palestinians are the indigenous peoples
despite there being uh Jews in the in
the land many years before anyone even
came up with the term Palestinian which
is a disputed term anyway um uh so they
they come up with this idea for instance
that they indigenous people who were who
were who were moved out the Palestinians
indigenous people and they were moved
out by the Jews the Israelis the
zionists and this version is of course a
replay of that version of American
History which is there with the idilic
edenic first populations of America the
indigenous peoples and then people from
Europe came the wicked Spanish and
Italians and Portuguese and the French
and even the British um come and do
their thing and so they they just put
this version of History onto the Middle
East to those people I would say fine
you can do that if you want now let's do
Britain want to play that
game you
sure you better not get the British
started but that's tell me more Douglas
what do you mean you want to play the
indigenous people own the land first
game and the other people should
off well it's 7 60 years of mass
migration into the UK who are the
indigenous peoples of the UK people
who've been here the longest who are the
settlers who are the illegal settlers in
Britain oh well that would be the people
who've
arrived does anyone want to go there
well you see Douglas I think what you're
saying is logically sound as you know
but I was very struck by something we
haven't released this episode yet but we
had a conversation with Michael malice
when we were an American uhhuh and he
said to me Constantine you've got to
realize at some point that these people
do not use language to communicate they
use language to manipulate sure and so
what you are saying makes sense except
they would say well no what do you mean
you are straight white or with not
straight white or whatever you are right
I'm a bluehead lesbian non-binary black
woman um that's not how they see you
Douglas well I self-identify
yes and the oppressed people are the
people with more melanin In Their
Skin well they should speak to the uh
the yemeni
Jews they should speak to the Ethiopian
Jews um they wouldn't even know what I
was talking about they can look they can
look it up they can educate themselves
the point is the point I'm trying to
make to you is we have a narrative in
this country certainly the the native
population or certainly the longest uh
living here native population they are
the oppressors and you know that all of
this is about this oppress oppressed
Dynamic so your argument in their world
doesn't work well the girls in Ram and
everyone everywhere else in uh Britain
who were raped by the thousands by
Pakistani rape gangs in the last 20
years were not the oppressors were
they I would say that they were the
oppressed but let me return to the
second uh class of person who is of the
left of the kind that I was mentioning
who the second class of crit critic of
Israel and uh we learn a lot from this
what are the other accusations that they
put apart from the Americanized social
justice versions what are the other
versions of of this that they put on it
they say the Israelis are committing
genocide that the Israelis are like the
Nazis that the Israelis were as bad as
Hitler now what is this first of all
uh we have to hit on the head the idea
that the Israel are committing genocide
which is Rife out there um it would be
the only only genocide in history in
which the population massively expanded
during said alleged
genocide the population of Gaza has shot
up in the last 18 years since Israel
withdrew so you could say that they are
extremely unsuccessful genocid
dists or people who would like to commit
genocide but haven't managed to for some
reason but none of the analysis of what
is actually happening and I and anyone
else who has traveled through the region
widely can tell you this it is nothing
like for instance what Bashar Al Assad
has done to the Syrian people over the
last 13 years it's nothing like what has
been happening uh in Yemen in the last
decade it is not anything approaching a
genocide that is happening in the West
Bank or Gaza so why do they say
it second why do they say like hit
third why do they say like the
Nazis these young people have been
brought up with only one bit of
Knowledge from history which is
Nazis and if you only know about one
thing from history it's likely that you
will decide that the whole of history
and the whole of the current day can
fall into two groups of people and be
analyzed by the lens of this one thing
Hitler not Hitler
unfortunately the these young people are
throwing out the only nasty accusation
they
know and they are picking it up from
people who are handing them the nastiest
thing that they could say why do I say
that they are picking up from mainly
Muslim prop Palestinian voices and pro
hamaz voices and others these
allegations which come from the Muslim
World against the Jewish State because
the Muslim world knows how much it will
wound the
Jews that's why they say that they say
the Jews are just like the Nazis because
they know how much that would hurt any
Jew now these young people who pick up
these arguments knowingly or otherwise
are repeating this slur on the Jewish
people and some of them will know how
much that hurts the Jews and will not
mind some of them may not know how much
that hurts the Jewish people uh why do
they keep why do these so-called prop
Palestinian peoples keep saying that
it's just like the warsa ghetto in Gaza
why choose the warsa ghetto why not
choose something not involving Jews why
not choose anything else from the
history of the world first of all by the
way it's not a very good comparison is
it because when the warsa when people
managed to escape briefly from the warsa
ghetto their first thing was not to run
out and behead the first child they
could
find but park that for a moment why do
they choose the war or ghetto because
they want to hurt Jews they want to hurt
them as deeply as they can here's the
other thing if you have this great
mistake of thinking that the whole world
can be divided into Hitler and not
Hitler these kids and kids they are are
going to discover if they have their way
that they were
Hitler why do I say that because if
their chant came true and from the River
Jordan to the medit ranean
sea
Palestine which is to say a state which
is uden rine because M Mahmud Abbas the
head of the Palestinian Authority as
well as Hamas who of course have been
running if you can call it at that the
Gaza for the last 13 years since they
killed the Palestinian Authority
representatives in
Gaza both Mahmud abas the head of the
allegedly moderate PA and hamz both
agree that Palestine must must be jew
free there is no scenario in the heads
of the Palestinian Authority or of Hamas
in which one Jew is allowed to live in
the Palestinian
state so if from The River To The Sea a
Palestinian state is created it will
mean either the eradication of all Jews
in Israel or the displacement of all
Jews in Israel which means cting out
every Jew from their historic Homeland
and either killing them or sending them
somewhere else and that would be done in
the name of being
antii these people have a huge problem
coming their way if they get their
way they're ignorant as hell and they
will have to hope to God that they never
get what they say they
want and Douglas this is one of the
things
that has really struck me because the
Israel Palestine issue we've had people
on the show to talk about it but it's
honestly not something that I have
really paid a huge amount of attention
to uh I say that with some regret now
but
nonetheless what has struck me is I
don't understand the double standards
that seem to apply to Israel I'd never
really paid attention to and therefore I
haven't but I don't understand I mean um
we're talking now about uh
proportionality
and this is they always do as long as it
involves Israel and I haven't understood
what that means exactly because I don't
think Israel would want to go into Gaza
and butcher innocent civilians by in the
way that Hamas did and also in a war
proportionality is moronic you're trying
to win yeah of course so why are people
calling for proportionality um because
they want Israel to lose that's all the
International Community always does this
um
there's you know not much love lost
across much of the world for Israel for
the same reasons as I described the much
of the Muslim world not having much love
for Israel um becomes The Whipping Boy
the scapegoat of the International
Community you know the joke that the the
UN should have a football team they was
well who would they play Israel
obviously um there was a vote at the UN
the other day uh a few days ago uh which
simply called for one thing which was
the international condemnation of the
Hamas massacres of the 7th of October it
didn't
pass didn't
pass uh the UN couldn't bring itself to
vote to condemn the massacre of the 7th
of October and when it was announced in
the hall that it hadn't um passed there
was much whooping and
clapping now we've seen this before of
course in 1975 there was a resolution at
the United nations in New York that
Zionism is
racism um one of those proposing this uh
um motion uh was ID
Amin fine upstanding gentleman good guy
yeah and again people watching who don't
know who ID Yamin is educate
yourself um and the evening uh that the
vote was put to the UN a drinks
reception was held at the United Nations
for those voting that Zionism was racism
and who was hosting the drinks party
Kurt
valheim again people can look him up C
Kurt valheim was a former Chancellor of
Austria uh he uh was a member of an SS
Battalion in World War
II so the United Nations has been here
before plenty of times the United
Nations can never bring itself to
condemn anything unless it involves
Israel and that is a pathol ology of the
United Nations but we have seen all of
this before many many times uh too many
times to count uh ever since the
foundation of the state and that comes
to one of the simple problems of and I'm
sorry but we have to bring it up
anti-Semitism one of the simple problems
about anti-Semitism is as everybody who
knows about it knows is that it's a
shapeshifting virus uh at one point in
the history of Europe in the history of
our own country the Jews were hated
uh because they were poor and then they
were hated because they were Rich uh
they were hated for not integrating and
then they were hated for integrating in
the era where you could hate people for
their religion they were hated for their
religion then when that not became
impossible in Europe you couldn't hate
people from their religion they were
hated for their race then at a
particular point in Europe we discovered
we couldn't hate people for their race
anymore so what did we hate people for
if they were Jewish we hated them for
being stateless then the Jewish people
got a state and they were hated for
having a state now you cannot tell me in
this situation that there's a
coincidence here uh um it is not a
coincidence that every way you do it it
ends up like that and great figures
including somebody I quoted a lot in
recent in recent days and weeks vasle
grman the great Russian novelist the
author of life and fate among other
works and everything flows he said
everything everything comes from this
and of course the Great thing the Gman
said the heart of his great novel In
Those few pages where he writes about
anti-Semitism about the dark heart of
the 20th century as he goes from
Stalingrad to trinka the great pages in
which grman takes the time out to talk
about anti-Semitism in the midnight of
the 20th century he says of course that
one he says some of what I've just said
about anism being a shape-shifting virus
because of course Hitler had it as
rather well known
uh but Stalin ended up with it as well I
mean it can go it goes every direction
everywhere um but as uh as grman greatly
says the thing about it is that it um it
tells you about the person who suffers
from it not about the Jews uh he says uh
tell me what you accuse the Jews of I'll
tell you what you're guilty
of people who uh hate the Jews for being
religious have religious problems
themselves people who hate the the fact
that Jews have a state that they're
willing to defend have a problem with
defending their own State themselves and
much much more on and on and on the
thing that and I've made this point in
in previous interviews so I have a
grandfather from from originally from
Lebanon Coptic Christian but he was an
anti-semite and people don't understand
when people comment in the west they
don't understand the depths of hatred
that exists in that region and I when I
say the the word hatred I mean it in its
true sense of the word people in the
west they don't understand that
emotion in the way that it it's
expressed over there they don't anymore
they could do in the years to come yeah
yeah and and to the point that you then
have people aining about it and I just
look at them and I go you have no idea
of what you're talking about you have no
idea you have no concept yeah you're
applying a western lens to judge a
problem or an issue which is is is not
Western yeah they
um well Israel in the era that we've
grown up uh Israel suffers from being
able to protect itself you
know something that Europeans will not
forgive it
for and uh many people in the west will
not forgive it for by the way um there's
a fascinating thing in that because of
course I mean Israelis really do try to
protect their borders mhm really do take
take it seriously when their borders are
are made poorest and um they really do
try to cere as a nation they try to
defend themselves as a nation they of
course have the draft so everybody is
involved in the defense of the nation
and this is all stuff that Europeans in
particular think is in the past you know
we're past borders we're past uh defense
we're past armies you know the mod and
the ministry of Defense in the UK you
know it effectively operates as an
NGO um and it does things like you know
it's a bit like that Hillary Clinton
thing that the where she said a little
while ago the first victims of war are
women not quite sure about that I think
I think I think they are of course
victims of war tends to be the first
victims of war the men who are fighting
and dying but anyway there's a bit of
the mod currently that's obsessed with
the issue of women in Conflict the
British Armed Forces if you remember um
I mean basically they have a recruitment
halt on white men at the moment because
they have certain race and gender um uh
quotas they've got to get to by 2030
which means that you can only do it if
you force a lot of women into roles in
the front line they don't always want
and uh um and and stop white men signing
up so we are in in a country like
Britain just
totally confused about all of this the
we don't have serious people well not
very many serious people and haven't had
for some time and the Israelis do have
to be serious and as we're reminded in
on the 7th of October you know when
things go wrong and something went very
many many things went very badly wrong
um but they have to respond I mean what
did we do in Britain when 23 young women
were blown up in a suicide bombing at
the Manchester Arena we cred don't look
back and we all diverted by the media
who told us Don't Look Back in Anger so
the idea that that that that we know
what to do in this situation is nonsense
we see the Israelis struggling through
things that we struggled through in
history and certain numbers of people
dislike them for having to struggle
through that still didn't you know we're
in this era where we just sing kayar
after we're attacked and and the one
that always stood out for me actually
even more so than the Manchester
bombings and that act of terrorism was
the murder of s David Amos oh yeah well
that was just memory hold by his own
colleagues in the most Shameless way
killed by a jihadist who sat beside his
body uh very pleased pleased with his
work and if you listened to the debate
in the house the next day or a couple of
days later in memory of s David Amos who
was killed what just over two years ago
if you listen to the debate in the house
you'd have thought he died of natural
causes I think his colleagues behaved
shamefully they all said how much they
wanted to pay tribute to his memory well
they didn't they
didn't they betrayed his
memory he was killed by somebody who was
an Islamic extremist supremacist
jihadist call him what you want the
whole of the House of Commons covered
for that now some people said to me
Douglas you cannot point this out you
might jeopardize the trial the reason
they're not saying this is because they
don't want to say these things ahead of
the trial this man is simply the suspect
the one you found covidence to David's
blood beside the body yes of course he's
still a suspect he mustn't prejudge from
the motives we'll put that discussion
off for another time when is the other
time the other time is after the
sentencing oh good I look forward to it
after the sentencing anything
crickets in this country in Britain we
can't uh seem to summon up the guts to
talk about this anytime anytime and you
know why because no one knows what to
do I would say it's because they're
scared douas if I'm honest they're
terrified because that the part of them
are thinking and they look at s s David
and I actually met s David it was a
wonderful man really man the an English
eccentric in the best sense of the word
but they're looking at him and they've
sat down and they've eaten lunch with
him and they've drunk with him and they
think that could be me well you
know what Joe Cox was also killed by an
extremist a lone wolf madman who seems
to have been inspired by some kind of
Neo-Nazi ideology and uh one of these
kind of
loser Fringe of the most
people and I don't remember after Joe
Cox's murder people saying let's not
prejudge why the murderer did it or
let's not spread any blame around I
don't remember that I missed that there
was an awful lot of spreading of blame
around they tried to blame everybody who
was about to vote brexit for the murder
they wanted to blame the whole leave EU
campaign for the
murder so I didn't see any lack of
prejudging there but I also didn't
notice that MPS were quiet in
identifying the ideology of the man who
had murdered their
colleague so why did they not
fear gangs of neonazi men coming around
and stabbing and decapitating MPS in the
name of neo- Nazism because it's not a
very big thing in Britain despite the
bogeyman's holding out of neo- nais has
always been about to take over don't
forget of course we live in a country
where the left uh uh the guardian and
others repeatedly describ suel braan as
far
right so although they use that language
they clearly don't believe it or mean it
because they would be fearful I mean I
don't doubt of course many MPS and many
I've spoken to from the labor party and
elsewhere were very very shocked by Joe
Cox's murder and it was deeply deeply
shocking but I think that most people
have recognized there are not very many
people in Britain actually
likely to to follow I hope that murder
of Joe Cox's extreme mad ideology there
was certainly nobody in the country who
would cover for him or say well he had a
point or anything like that nobody
wanted to be near that
filth
but why do they not identify it in this
case and why are they fearful in this
case because they know that the problem
exists and is bigger than they want to
admit
now there's a
problem we'll be back with our guest in
a minute but first we want to take a
moment to talk about our partners GIF
and go GIF and go is a leading
crowdfunding website where thousands of
people around the world raise funds for
business ventures medical expenses
personal needs nonprofits churches and
funeral costs on giv and go you can
raise money for whatever you need we've
met the people at giv and go and and we
can tell you that they're absolutely
aligned with trigonometry on our
approach to free speech they don't just
talk the talk they walk the walk unlike
other big tech companies they like us
believe that with openness and honesty
will create more understanding and
ultimately more Harmony in the world
gifs and go is absolutely free to use
with other crowdfunding sites you'll pay
between 5 and 10% of the money you raise
give send go charge no money at all to
use their platform they believe you
should be able to keep all the money you
raise on giv and go you can choose to
raise funds for short or long-term
campaigns whether you're in the USA UK
Australia or anywhere in the world gifs
and ghost supports freedom of speech
they won't cave to the Mob and that's
why we are proud to partner with them
starting a campaign on gien go is easy
and intuitive go to gien go.com today
start raising money for whatever's
important to you and support the people
who support Freedom now back to the
interview I agree with you I also agree
with Francis but I agree with you the
reason people don't want to say anything
is they don't know what to
do and I've spent the last three weeks I
said it in the speech that I gave it Arc
uh in a pretty dark place because I like
to think I'm a pretty clever guy I talk
to people like you who are way more
clever than me and to many others and I
say to them the same thing how does this
get fixed because what I see is we have
an open border
mhm and we there is despite the fact
there was a poll done in recent weeks
which showed that 92% of conservative
voters and 70% of Labor voters which was
higher than I expected support deporting
people who glorify terrorism MH and yet
we sit here all three of us knowing full
well as everybody watching this does
that despite the fact fact that we have
a quote unquote far-right
government that is never ever going to
happen well it might not happen under
this government but it'll happen one to
one in the
future um the first thing is the British
public is totally right um uh I do not
want to live in a country with Hamas
supporters I want them deported I want
them chucked
out simple and I will do everything I
can to ensure that happens uh I am fed
up by the way of the Centrist dad hang
hand ringing in era where people say oh
but might it be against our liberal
values and might might our liberalism
I'm not as interested in that as I am in
Britain remaining
Britain I am much more interested in
that at every time of national emergency
in our nation's history we gave
something up to
survive we did in the Napoleonic Wars we
did in the wars of the 20th century and
we will have to now
this is the thing we give up extending
tolerance to people who do not extend it
back to us it should be over that era
the first person who must be deported
from the UK and have his citizenship
withdrawn is a man called Muhammad saala
who lives in North London I am happy to
start handing out his address if need be
Muhammad saala is a former military
commander of Hamas in the West Bank he
has been living peacefully
uh in the UK that is undisturbedly I
should say undisturbed in the UK for
many years now under the last Labor
government he seems to have got UK
citizenship now to get UK citizenship
you have among other things to show that
you're a person of good character I
would submit that if you are a military
commander of Hamas you are not a person
of good
character now what is to be done about
this man he is currently not in the UK
he is in Istanbul and again I'm very
happy to give out his location should
people want
it I do not want that man back in my
country I don't want him here if he
arrives back here he should be arrested
and
deported now I would also like him to go
to the
Gaza Muhammad saala should not be in the
UK the name of this man is now out there
it was put on the front page of the
Sunday time some a couple of weeks ago I
immediately got my lawyers to write the
Home Secretary the Prime Minister the
director of public prosecutions and the
Attorney General saying that if they do
not prosecute him I will get a
prosecution
myself uh this man cannot live in my
country he will be the first and we will
see how many more need to come after him
he should not have British citizenship
we do not want him here we have not
benefited from his being here let me
throw one other name straight out there
who should be on the same list
um a man called Maharani the former
deputy prime minister of Iran he lives
in Harrow again I'm very happy to start
giving his address out why does he live
in leafy Harrow this man we don't know
the last Labor government gave him right
to remain in the
UK who is
Maharani two things might be of interest
one he was the man who the
ayahi got to write the book length
justification of the Fatar calling
calling for the murder of the British
novelist Salman
rushi why is Salman Rush's life in such
Peril and has been since Valentine's Day
1989 and Maharani lives peacefully in
leafy
Harrow I don't want him to Second apart
from justifying a calling for the murder
of a British novelist Maharani was also
involved in the prison massacres of
leftists and Communists in Iran in the
1980s one of his former colleagues has
been prosecuted for war crimes in a in a
European Court in the last year I see no
reason why Maharani should not also be
prosecuted under the same uh um
crimes why should we live with these
people why should they be
here my forbears didn't fight off
generation after generation of enemies
only to have these enemies given the
right to remain
here we'd have no need of them our
country has not benefited from them get
them out get them out and if the
government will not do it at some point
the people will do it and I would submit
that will be much
uglier and
it's you know at one point Douglas I
would have said you know this is too far
but the thing even above the S David
Amos and coming as a former
teacher the thing that
really opened my eyes to the cowardice
within our
institutions was the Batley Grammar
School case yes absolutely shameful and
the capitulation of the Union the
refusal to stand by their member which
is a workingclass tradition going back
Generations one of the finest traditions
of the unions and they just abdicated
responsibility and it just shows for me
that there is very few people in power
who've got the backbone to be willing to
tackle this I think that's right well
the people who do want to tack it will
come to power well Douglas this is a
thing that has been discussed and I want
to raise with you I mean I agree with
you um and I saw Ron desantes uh the
American presidential candidate he gave
a speech in which he said the point of
immigration is to bring people who are
going to benefit our country and I
thought I haven't heard someone say that
for about 20
years as a politi yeah quite which to me
seems like a fairly uncontroversial
statement
actually but the argument that I see
going around online I mean these people
specifically that you're talking about I
think few would argue about oh I bet
they would anyway well if they don't
argue about it why not do it quite um
and I want to come back to that as well
but the one thing I see is particularly
American uh commentators uh say well
look the right in particular has been
banging on about Free Speech endlessly
and then you have these people go out on
a protest and suddenly everyone saying
they should be deported mhm uh what do
you say to those people first of all not
everyone saying they should be deported
a small number of us are um yeah I I
have some friends on the um sort of
libertarian right as it were as well as
people on the left who say but you're
such a free speech activist how could
you how could you deny the rights of
free speech to people who simply want to
stand outside synagogues taunting Jews
for the murder of their fellow
Jews
well this is not a practice of free
speech this is not an interesting test
case of free speech it's very
straightforward throughout our history
as I mentioned earlier we have
repeatedly been a been willing to say
that certain things Trump are most
cherished values and the main one is our
ability to
survive I would say that at the moment
we are at a very important Point not
least with policing in the UK the
protests have taken place in recent
weeks and the protests that have already
been announced for the weeks ahead have
been a great test for the Metropolitan
Police and other police forces across
the UK and it is a test that they have
failed
monumentally now I know the policing
decision they've made part of the
policing decision
clearly is that they will observe the
crowd and they will see if anyone breaks
the law and if they do break the law
they may get a visit at some point later
from the the police and they may be
arrested this happened in the 2000s with
ANM charry and the group members of Al
harun it was a very similar thing there
was once actually an occasion when um
mun came to me personally in the Streets
of London and I was amazed that the
British police didn't do more to protect
me or
um well anyway and it turned out that
they were doing the same thing which is
they hang back in order to arrest people
later um well here's the problem with
that the world only sees the crime being
committed the world does not see the
followup the world is very interested
and watching The Streets of London at
the moment and are horrified by what
they
see they do not see the tiny number of
arrests the Metropolitan Police has been
willing to actually carry out of people
who are supporting him as on our streets
and not only that by the way Douglas we
saw a couple of years ago people who
drove down from Blackburn quite far away
from London to go into Jewish areas and
uh through megaphone shout rape Jewish
women kill Jewish women all of
us the mother fck the daughters and
show the supp Shut Them Up rap the
daughters those people were arrested and
not prosecuted yes um maybe they should
have tweeted it yeah they should have um
they should have uh called them what was
the crime that Lawrence Fox committed
again that b the whole world crashing
down a few weeks ago they should have
said they wouldn't shag them which is
the opposite of what they seem to be
wasn't that a good should they should
have gone through Jewish erors saying I
wouldn't
Shack that would have got the police
interested and probably
ofcom that would have got the guardian
going for
months my God we've been diverted
haven't we
um here's the thing the the police uh
are also of course in this strange case
of several cases we now have on camera
of the police taking down the posters of
missing stolen Jewish children that have
been put up in London and other places
and as well as being ripped down by um
Muslims in the UK and leftists in the UK
they've also now been taken down by
police in the UK we have footage of the
metropolitan police taking down these
posters uh two things about that if I
may the first is we should follow the
example of some blue collar workers in
New York and elsewhere in America
recently who have found these scumbags
taking down posters and confronted them
if the police are not going to confront
people ripping down posters and trying
to hurt Jews on the streets of Britain
again I would like the public to do so
and I think the public should start to
do so and that is what will happen if
the police do not protect the public the
public will have to start protecting the
public
the second thing may I just on that
sure aren't we being slightly dishonest
at Douglas the demographic situation in
the UK is very different um it is I
don't I don't know that if I was to
challenge somebody in the street doing
that that I frankly at this point would
have the support of the people around me
I wonder if I might find myself in a
minority okay well what will happen at
some point is that a group of people who
are in a majority will come down from
some other part of L of the UK and
they'll do it themselves and who would
say that that was a bad
thing at this point yeah at this point
if this is all all on the table oh
they're going to regret it the police
are going to deeply regret this so
that's the first thing the second thing
is uh and let me be as clear as possible
on this the police clearly seem to think
in the UK that the big problem is that
it is provocative to put up posters of
Abdu Ed Jewish
children and that is because it will
provoke Community tensions this by the
way is not a fringe view it is a view
clearly shared by a number of
politicians across the UK most
prominently certain Muslim politicians
across the
UK here let us be totally Frank if there
are people in the UK who are offended by
the posters of missing Jewish children
they must leave the UK we do not want
them it is not Jews who should be
fearful in the UK it is the people who
would make Jews fearful they must leave
it is shameful to me that in the last
few weeks I have had friends from around
the world including Jewish friends
saying is it safe any longer to come to
England to come to Britain specifically
to come to
London it is not Jews who should fear
being in London it is the people who
would make them fearful so at some point
the Jews who are a very small minority
in the UK a little over
200,000 they are dwarfed by the large
size of the Muslim Community in the UK
at the moment but fine the non-muslim
population of the UK is far
larger and by and large in my experience
they are very good people the British
still have pride in their past that has
not been beaten out of them they still
have a sense of the goodness of our
nation of the pride of our nation of
what it has done in the past that we
should be grateful for and proud of and
what it might still do now despite
Decades of indoctrination to try to tell
us that we are wicked that is really
only belev by a small number of people
who happen to have control of many of
the major institutions and have a
disproportionate voice in the media and
a disproportionate presence in what used
to be called
Academia fine we'll do this without them
do you not worry Douglas that with what
you're saying that we're going to be
pretty soon not that you're advocating I
want to make that clear that we're going
to be on the path to a pretty unpleasant
government pretty soon well we' got
starm of course but that's a different
things what we have what we'll have is
this will all be
suppressed again and again and again
until you can't suppress it
anymore and it will not be a matter of
party affiliation or parties in power
it'll simply start to happen on the
streets uh the British public are being
pushed beyond our
endurance and if we are waiting for a
political Outlet I think that a large
number of people will start to think we
don't have a political Outlet the Home
Secretary and the government say things
and yet they do not
happen the labor parties say things and
promise things and yet they do not
happen I'm old enough to remember when
the last Labor government whil
ratcheting up Mass immigration into the
UK talked about the dangers of mass
immigration I well remember people like
what was his name uh uh there was a
there was a labor immigration minister
in about 2007 who gave a front page
interview to the times of London which
he talked about the downside of
multiculturalism how everything had gone
wrong with it and we needed to get
control of our
borders we've heard these people from
right and left labor and conservative
none of them ever do what they say and
it seems impared because they
can't so I very much fear again as you
say I'm not advocating it I'm observing
it I very much fear that in the years
ahead this is past the
parties more people are members of the
bird watchers Association of the UK then
belong to all of the nation's political
parties so clearly people don't believe
the political parties are the way
forward or any or able to do anything or
anything
much so we'll see what's happened but
you know the public didn't get us here I
was asked by a senior member of the BBC
shortly after the atrocities of
2017 what I thought had gone wrong and
why the BBC and others were now
incapable of speaking to the general
public and were missing the general
public and I remember this person said
to me what should we do Douglas and I
said it's a bit late now isn't it I said
I feel when you ask me this and expect
my answer like somebody who has been
pushed deliberately into a swimming pool
in their full clothing and then asked
why they're
wet I didn't want to be here I didn't
want my nation to be here but we've been
pushed
here we'll see what we do Douglas I want
to ask you about the role of the BBC and
the media more generally but we'll
continue this conversation on locals
we'll do about 40 minutes or so on there
uh because we've done almost an hour
here so uh follow us over
there Dave the Kiwi says we need people
like Constantine and Douglas
representing the UK in public office has
it ever crossed the minds of either of
them to stand as
[Music]
MPS